bien on dirait que l'heure de ma
vengeance a sonné nico qu'êtes vous non
c'est vrai que nous sommes jamais
rencontrés mais tu dois te souvenir de
mon frère aussi faire l'oci faire c'est
votre c'est votre frère c'était mon
frère avant que tu me détruisent
johnny n'a rien à voir dans cette
histoire c'est même pas mon frère pour
de vrai vrai ou faux
toi au moins il te reste un frère
même si ce n'est plus pour longtemps la
part du grand jour on peut vraiment pas
se laisser 5 minutes comment tu es pas
le seul à savoir voler seul frais dire
attraper les très légèrement à gauche ou
bien j'ai dit à gauche
et ça c'est pas à gauche c'est qu'elle
congélo remblais ou s'en fiche vo lu ça
s'oublie pas chez sur la cobas je veux
la voir
rires non je ne veux pas nous vanter
tous en même temps accrochez vous bien
et laissez faire le maître je vais pas
plus compliqué que ça il faut vraiment
que je fasse du moine elle
quoi
arrêt pl comme un pinceau c'est toi ton
problème désoler et ce à cause des
plumes jeu super sat ou yeux et c'est
moi qui les ai choisis